Katy Perry reveals the sweet way she met
her fiance Orlando Bloom Katy is finally
telling the world about her dreamy man
the singer has been notoriously private
about Orlando we know this but on the
American Idol season premiere she shared
how they first met I met my boyfriend
over in and out you did we were at the
Golden Globes and we were we work
together and so I had my security guard
grabbed in and out oh my god and all of
a sudden I see my boyfriend's pan he
wasn't even singing at our table
he just swoops in and he grabs it I'm
like hey that's my boo-boos
it was love at first bite for Katy in
Orlando the singer first talked about
the magical moment while on Jimmy Kimmel
Live he stole one off of my table I was
sitting with Denzel Washington and he
took it and I was like wait oh you're so
hot fine take it and then I saw him at a
party and I was like how are those
onions resting on your molars he's like
I like you and then you know cut to last
month Orlando popped the question on
Valentine's Day and gave us all the
feels the power couple shared this
featuring a one-of-a-kind flower ring
and experts get this estimate that Katy
sparkler cost up to two million dollars
that's a lot of bling on someone's
finger yeah I'd be nervous to wear that
absolutely now Katy also revealed the
deeps behind Orlando sweet proposal
during her stop by Jimmy Kimmel Live and
let's just say it wasn't exactly smooth
sailing it was really sweet he asked me
to marry him in a helicopter actually
the funny part is we had champagne in
the helicopter and the box was in his
pocket and he had written down
everything he wanted to say in a note
you know to divert
right he's gonna pull it out while I'm
reading it so I'm reading it but I'm
hearing like the champagne is like
broken the bottles everywhere and I'm
still looking at the note because he
he's pulling out this box that's too big
for his coat pocket it rips his coat
pocket and his elbow goes into the
champagne and I'm like no I'm just
reading the note I know you're not doing
anything but things took a turn for the
better
they landed he did land and it was like
James Bond like everybody had like an
earpiece and then we go downstairs we
landed on a rooftop and my whole family
was oh that's great he did so well now
this of course is going to be the second
marriage for both Katie and Orlando he
was married to Miranda Kerr from 2010 to
2013
and the two have an eight-year-old son
Flynn now Katie was married to Russell
Brand you might remember from 2010 to
2012 I think every relationship is
everyone's a teacher in a relationship
that's how I see it now and we've taught
each other a lot after meeting in 2016
the pair dated until February 2017
before calling it quits kaboom rekindled
their romance in January 2018 a source
told ET one of the main reasons for
their split was quote the pressures of
constantly being in the public eye and
not taking the time alone to just be
together the on-again couple made it a
priority to start taking these trips
together and a source adds that time
together created quote a stronger sense
of trust and appreciation for each other
though in and out is responsible for
building their bond Orlando is all about
creating a healthy lifestyle for them
the man works out looks good I mean he's
always trying to get me a hike Yoga eat
vegan oh my god it is like I'll hike to
Taco Bell with you I sure will
Crunchwrap supreme extra my extra onion
it's no secret katie is extra in love
with her fiance and food obviously oh
yeah have you ever fallen in love over
burger never any food pizza I love food
but I haven't fallen in love over it but
guys this seems really fitting that food
is what brought these two lovebirds
together I love this and for all the
latest good bloom news be sure to
subscribe to ET until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens and I'm Courtney teza
know bye for now guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]